it's great to welcome back to the
program today Andrew Seidel who's a
civil rights and constitutional attorney
with the Freedom From Religion
Foundation where he serves as the
director of strategic response works to
keep state and church separate his new
book is the founding myth why Christian
nationalism is unamerican Andrew so
great to have you back on thank you for
having me on it really is a pleasure I
appreciate it David so we recently did a
story which was called something like
the founding fathers were progressive
and you should be too and with without
getting into the sort of politics of it
there is this idea which was part of
that story that we did our best to
debunk which is the idea that because
all of the founding fathers were
Christian that there is either some
explicit or implicit reasoning behind
saying the United States is
fundamentally a Christian nation now
before we get to part two of that the
first question we have to ask is where
the founding fathers actually Christian
what we found is that while they were
mostly deists they were not actually
mostly Christian as is often described
but my question to you is does that even
really matter in figuring out whether
the United States should have this sort
of motto or umbrella term of being a
Christian nation is the is the religion
of the founding fathers even relevant to
that my contention is that it is not and
this is the argument that I try to make
in the founding myth it's a really
interesting conversation and it's
fascinating to delve into the beliefs of
the founders but when you're talking
about well is this actually a Christian
nation it doesn't matter so if it let's
say let's just agree for a second for
the sake of argument that all the
founders were these Bible believing
Jesus rose from the dead Christians you
would still then have to connect those
beliefs to the founding of the United
States and just because somebody is
religious their religion doesn't claim
ownership over every other idea that
their mind generates you know for
instance blue jeans were invented by two
Jewish guys but we don't go around
calling them Jewish blue jeans they're
just blue jeans
well you some of the YouTube comments I
get before you say nobody's doing that
but yeah I don't think we shouldn't be
doing that yeah and we don't think we
can judge everything by the YouTube
comments because they do yes yeah
nikka generates quick down there sorry
everybody the larger point I think is
you would still have to connect it to
the founding and you can't do that and
when you look at what the founders
talked about and believed and actually
wrote in to the founding documents they
really did believe in the separation of
state and church they were trying to
keep religion out of government and
government out of religion and those
were kind of that was kind of one of the
big ideas that was unique to America it
was the first time that that had been
put into practice and it was I mean it's
the it's the American invention then
probably our biggest contribution to
political science and we ought to be
proud of that fact as Americans proud of
the separation of state and church
I ended proud of its progressive
leanings I think as well so if if indeed
the original founders were did not have
this belief of sort of Christian
nationalism as the basis for the United
States of America and now there is a
wing of the American political sphere
that does have that belief at some point
something made that belief start among a
certain wing of the American political
sphere where did that start where did it
come from where did this idea this
talking point that became very prevalent
in certain political circles start from
if not with the actual founders that and
that's a fascinating question so
Christian national Christian nationalism
is really this idea that the United
States not only was founded as a Judea
as a Christian nation but it was founded
on judeo-christian principles yeah and
put that Dakota to that is that it needs
to return to those principles so really
and that is the that's the driving
motivating force for Christian
nationalists they're trying to get this
returned this the and it's it's Golden
Age thinking really accept that the
problem for them is that we never were
founded as a Christian nation so you saw
it really ride the rise of Christian
nationalism began with sort of the rise
of the moral majority and it wouldn't it
didn't really get that name Christian
nationalism until the mid 2000s and it
was always sort of this impotent little
sideshow on the fringes of conservative
politics on the fringes of conservative
religion
but that all changed with the 2016
election because Donald Trump rode a
wave of Christian nationalism into the
highest office in the land I mean he is
not president in spite of his Christian
nationalist leanings and rhetoric but
because of that Christian nationalist
rhetoric
yeah and that gets us to making this
distinction which is an important one
between someone between Christianity so
to speak and Christian nationalism
because I think as many have obviously
pointed out if you compare Donald
Trump's philosophy and the way he's
lived his life to the sort of Christian
Bible you see a lot of contradictions
there you see a lot of problems but
ultimately most evangelical Christians
did vote for Donald Trump and it seems
to me Andrew and correct me if I'm wrong
wrong that underlying it is that even
though Donald Trump may not have
personally lived his life as a Christian
the nationalistic undertones of Donald
Trump's campaign are in line with this
broader idea of Christian nationalism
that seems to be kind of separate from
one identifying as a Baptist or or or as
an evangelical for example know that and
that's absolutely right and it's really
important that people understand that
the number one predictor of whether or
not somebody would vote for Donald Trump
in the 2016 election was not political
party and it was not their religion
I wasn't even whether or not they were
racist socioeconomic status none of that
the number one predictor was whether or
not somebody believed that the United
States was a Christian nation so
Christian nationalism was the best
indicator of whether or not somebody was
would have been a Donald Trump voter in
the 2016 election that data is pretty
ironclad now Andrew Whitehead out of the
University of Clemson has done a number
of studies on this it's it's very clear
so Trump wasn't tapping into even the
Republican Party or even into the
evangelical movement
there's just happens to be a huge
overlap between those two and Christian
nationalism that was really what he was
tapping into to win this election
what about that's a little more
amorphous idea of the you you alluded to
it already
judeo-christian values which is we can
we can slice and dice the exact
religions of the founders we can talk
about separation of church and state in
some kind of formal or legal sense but
it's undeniable some will say that the
sort of
the mental moral infrastructure of the
United States was based on the
judeo-christian and really - that means
Christian because there were almost no
Jews who were part of this group mostly
Christian people Christian Christian
insight in terms of the values again not
in terms of necessarily identifying as
Baptist or whatever the case may be who
said we want to leave England and settle
the new world in order to have full
religious freedom how do we take on that
argument which is a little bit more
nebulous and blurry and and that's
exactly what I try to do in the founding
myth and it is more nebulous and blurry
and that's why it's the fallback
position if you can push back on were
not founded as a Christian nation the
next argument you always get is well I
really meant we were founded on
judeo-christian principles and that's
really what the founding myth pushes
back on and so what I did was I actually
compared the judeo-christian principles
from the Bible I looked at every one of
the Ten Commandments and then I compared
those to the founding principles the
United States to those elements of
political science and political
philosophy that the founders used to
actually build this country and I what I
discovered was not just that
judeo-christian principles didn't
influence the founding but that they're
fundamentally opposed to the founding of
the United States what give like a one
or two examples of that if you can I
mean the best example would be let's
just focus on the first of the first
commandment right the first commandment
is I am the Lord your God you shall have
no other gods before me
it runs completely counter to one of our
founding principles religious liberty
you can worship no God you can worship a
hundred gods you get to have free
religious liberty in this in this
country and if you were to follow the
Ten Commandments you only get to worship
that biblical God and that's it so
there's this fundamental conflict so
it's not only that we weren't founded on
judeo-christian values or principles but
it's a good thing we weren't otherwise
we wouldn't have the values and the
freedoms that we so cherish today so if
we decided to cherry-pick only the areas
in which maybe there does seem to be
significant overlap between the sort of
founding values in Christianity just as
a thought experiment for a second we
then get to the problem of sort of
correlation and causation and I've
actually heard a number of of thinkers
point out that just because most of the
individuals who made big advancements in
for example stone tools metal tools
maybe it's a better example were
adherents to a certain religion that
doesn't really give us any causal case
for the religion being a factor it may
just be that at the time there was a
sort of default to a particular
religious belief so to speak a lot of
the values that do seem to overlap
between the founders of the US and
Christianity are values that existed
much more than 5,000 years ago in human
societies anyway some of the question is
are they really even Christian values
and that's a really excellent point and
it is one that I do make in the founding
myth in a couple different places one
thing that we often hear is well the
United States is it was founded on the
Golden Rule and I think that's a hard
argument to make actually but I just
assume for the sake of argument in the
book that that is true but then the
liquid next question is well is the
golden rule really a Christian principle
and my argument is that it's not this is
a universal human principle that every
successful society we know of has
developed on its own I mean a 2 3 4
year-old child can understand the idea
of reciprocal morality it's it's really
not a difficult concept and to allow
Christian Christianity or even Christian
nationalism to claim it as its own is is
to me a form of arrogance that that I
don't think we should allow to stand can
you talk a little bit about slogans like
In God We Trust on money or one nation
under God or the addition of a reference
to God in the Pledge of Allegiance and
the role that those slogans have in
perpetuating these ideas of the United
States as a Christian nation I mean they
have a huge role in perpetuating that
myth and the role is deliberate so you
know one thing that I think maybe our
site is pretty good at when it comes to
pushing back on those those mottos is
pointing out that none of those are from
the founding generation but then we tend
to leave it at that and in the founding
myth I really wanted to go beyond that I
so I explore how these
phrases entered our vernacular and it
turns out that they were deliberately
put there during times of national fear
and strife when you had a few very few a
handful in each case Christians
Christian nationalists we would call
them today trying to use their public
office to promote their personal
religion so you know you have this
happening during the height of the Civil
War when the country is literally
tearing itself apart and people aren't
paying attention to what's being
inscribed on the coinage and yet it's
basically three guys responsible for
getting it on there at that point the
same thing was happening in the 1950s
where we ended up with the National Day
of Prayer and under God in the pledge
that it was this time of national fear
and so it's not just that they're taking
advantage of a country that's scared and
fearful but they're also wiping out
unifying sentiments with religion which
tends to be really divisive you know and
so our original de facto motto was a
pluribus unum from one people or from
one from many people one nation from
many states one country and they wiped
that out within god we trust'
and the same thing happened with the
Pledge of Allegiance it used to read one
nation individual indivisible which is
this beautiful sentiment and then
they're literally dividing the
indivisible with God so it's not just
they're taking advantage of times of
fear and strife and then they're wiping
out unifying sentiments to promote their
personal religion this seems way bigger
to me than partisan politics in the
sense that okay I mean there are
candidates whose philosophy is more of a
departure from the sort of thinking that
gets you to Christian nationalism so
there are differences I'm not pretending
that Trump and Biden and Bernie are all
sort of like the same on this but but in
a sense this is a much bigger cultural
thing this relates to the courts and the
Supreme Court in ways that that kind of
transcend many decades so how does
something like this change in a country
when who we elect is only like a small
piece of it you're absolutely right and
right now it's infecting all kinds of
policy immigration policy we saw it in
the Muslim ban Education Policy Betsy
DeVos is essentially trying to dismantle
public education all of those are on the
back of Christian nationalism
foreign-policy we're seeing and you are
right that courts judges and not just
Trump judges are deciding cases based on
some of the myths and the lies that I
try to expose in my book but you're also
right to say that it's bigger because at
its most basic level what this is is an
attempt to redefine what it is to be an
American they are trying to say that to
be an American you have to be a
Christian and to be a Christian is to be
an American and once they've redefined
the American identity like that they're
going to redefine all of our laws
accordingly and to me that is one of the
central reasons why I say that Christian
nationalism is unamerican it's not just
that those judeo-christian principles
often are directly opposed to our
founding values it's that this entire
movement is meant to redefine what it is
to be an American in an unamerican way
we've been talking a lot about the
content of Andrew sidles new book the
founding myth why Christian nationalism
is unamerican but there's much more
great stuff in it
Andrew always great to talk to you and I
really appreciate your time David thank
you so much it's always a pleasure